- Hope he's doing a good job.
Billy, no jazz.
♪ ♪
Hey, Tim.
- Hey, Sam.
This is Bruce from
1-2-3 Warehouse.
Just a new client to I've added
to our portfolio.
I know he's just a small fish,
but still fun to reel in.
- I'm not a small fish.
- But you are, you are.
- Yeah, of course, Bruce,
welcome to Royals.
- I ate here once before.
- Well, then, welcome back.
- Yep, just pitching Bruce
here some taglines.
You know, closing the deal.
You used to do that.
Wanna sit in?
- No, Tim, I can't.
But you've got this.
Bruce, you're
in excellent hands.
Enjoy your meals, fellas.
It's on me.
- Oh.
- Not the booze, though.
- So I was wrong,
he's not gonna join us.
No worries,
I can do it myself.
Uh, so we see beauty shots
of your wonderful appliances.
A family walks through
the store holding a map.
The announcer comes on,
"1-2-3 Warehouse.
"Where's the warehouse?
It's as easy as
1-2-3 Warehouse."
- It's going to seem like
they're lost in the store.
- Okay, you don't like that?
Here's another one.
"1-2-3 Warehouse,
it's as easy
as A-B-C. Warehouse."
- My main competitor
is A-B-C Warehouse.
- Uh, that's insane.
- All right, well, just take
that off their check,
and then give them
a free dessert.
- Okay.
- Thanks, Darren.
- Hey, don't grab me!
- I didn't grab you!
You looked away
when I was talking to you.
I'm not gonna apologize for
something that I didn't do.
- You grabbed my shirt.
- Shirt!
So you admit that
I didn't grab you!
- Uh, gentlemen, some wine
for the table.
Sorry to interrupt,
but how about something like
"1-2-3 Warehouse:
you can count on us."
- I love it.
Because you can count
on 1-2-3.
That's perfect.
- It is.
It is, perfect.
Sam, come back.
Tell me you didn't get
a rush from that.
Clients are coming in now.
Way better than this guy,
trust me.
- Hey.
- Tim, I'm not coming back.
Look, in ten years,
I'm gonna be managing
four of these restaurants.
And, hopefully,
Cramblin Duvet's the biggest
ad agency in Detroit, but, Tim,
I can't gamble on hopefully.
'Cause in 10 years my kid's
gonna be nine,
and, if he's anything like me,
he's gonna need braces
for his legs
'cause his dick's so big.
Good luck, buddy.
I love ya.
- Love you too.
All right, okay,
well, we can't
use "you can count on us"
for legal reasons,
plus I refuse to do that.
But I'll come up with
something just as good.
Um, one...
Look at me when
I'm talking to you!